eu faço parte de uma família de oito
filhos e meu pai sempre falou que pra
gente não dar trabalho pra ele ele tinha
que dar trabalho pra gente
por isso a gente sempre trabalhou desde
cedo e meu pai sempre trabalhou muito
foi um susto quando aos 62 anos ele
decidiu se aposentar e ele decidiu se
aposentar aos 62 que ele tinha certeza
que morreu seu tempo
essa referência dele e dos pais dos avós
[Música]
até que quando ele fez 65 66
ele entendeu ele não ia morrer tão cedo
porque ele estava muito bem tava com
muita saúde estava felizão taubaté subiu
em árvore
naquele momento ele tinha que escolher
ele se deparou com uma pergunta o que
fazer com esse tempo que ele ganhou de
presente
ele tinha dois caminhos o primeiro que
era se reinventar e o segundo que era
ficar esperando a morte chegar
felizmente e como não ia ser diferente
meu pai está aqui eles podem tomar um
café com ele depois ele escolheu pelo
primeiro
hoje com quase 70 meu pai está
empreendendo de novo ele tem uma agenda
lotada mais lotado que a minha está num
relacionamento novo e dizer que quer
ainda mais dois filhos
vamos ver
a realidade do meu pai a realidade de
quase 30 milhões de brasileiros
esses novos maduros eles estão
revolucionando a vida
eles são muito diferentes dos
estereótipos do passado do velhinho de
bengala ou da vovozinha que ficava na
cadeira de balanço
ele já são mais do que a população do
chile do uruguai juntos e no brasil já
movimentam mais de 1 trilhão de reais
no mundo mais de 15 trilhões de dólares
e se a gente juntar se todo esse
dinheiro já seria terceira maior
economia do planeta
logo atrás da china e dos estados unidos
aqui no brasil não sei se vocês sabem a
gente já tem mais a voz do que netos
a gente já tem mais pessoas com mais de
60 anos do que crianças até 5 anos de
idade e muito em breve
pessoas com mais de 60 anos do que
adolescentes até 14 anos de idade pra
eles
e na verdade pra todo mundo o tempo
esticou e essa é uma boa notícia
a gente tem a oportunidade de criar
diversas vidas dentro da nossa própria
vida
um dos elementos que está revolucionando
a longevidade é o smartphone da tv para
o celular
a tela diminuiu mas a janela aumentou e
hoje todo maduro carrega no bolso uma
janela para o mundo
se antes do dia passava devagar restrito
ao aposento hoje os maduros às vezes
recebem a de 50 até 60 bom dia no a tap
e ali neste aplicativo que eles
encontram seus amigos que eles discutem
sobre política que eles trocam dicas
caseiras e mais eles falam sobre sonhos
e sobre futuro e quais são os sonhos
desses novos maduros em 2018
ao lado da parte social agente
entrevistou duas mil e quinhentas
pessoas entre si
85 e 90 anos de idade para entender quem
são o que pensam o que querem e quais os
tabus que essas pessoas estão
desconstruindo na nossa sociedade
o resultado desse estudo é o tsunami 60
mais o maior estudo sobre economia
prateado em raio x da população no
brasil em uma entre tantas entrevistas e
tantas pessoas que a gente conheceu tem
a história do seu raimundo seu raimundo
tem 72 anos ele mora na periferia de são
paulo
e quando a gente chegou na casa dele
tinha ali no quintal um tanto de
eletrodomésticos
a gente achou que era o trabalho dele
que ele fazia isso por dinheiro mas não
e ele nunca tinha feito isso na vida a
gente perguntou como ele tinha aprendido
a fazer isso quando a gente chegou
dentro da casa dele do quarto tinha um
laptop no youtube no canal do youtube
com o vídeo como consertar microondas e
o seu raimunda aprendeu então pelo
youtube uma nova profissão uma nova uma
nova posição profissão um novo papel
etapa que estava lhe desempenhando na
sua comunidade estava fazendo isso de
graça
já débora amiga e ela é mãe de uma amiga
super querida e ela encontrou os amigos
dela pelo facebook amigos do tempo de
escola que ela não via há 35 anos
hoje esses amigos criaram um grupo de
what's up se falam todos os dias eles se
encontram uma vez por mês e mais do que
ficar lembrando as histórias do passado
eles estão criando novas histórias
os maduros então estão em todos os
aplicativos e todas as novas tecnologias
mesmo que elas não tenham sido feitas
pra eles no huerb o grupo que mais
cresce no brasil e no mundo é dos hosts
anfitriões 50 mais e são eles que
recebem as melhores estrelinhas no hub
isso também não é diferente quem aqui
nunca entrou no ver com maduro no
volante
geralmente são aqueles homens que se
aposentaram voltaram pra casa viram que
ali eles não tinham muito espaço ou a
mulher expulso ele só assim vai lá vai
fazer alguma coisa e eles foram virar
motoristas para além de fazer uma renda
extra também se divertir passear pela
cidade conversar
os números então não mentem mais de 90%
têm batem latapy mais de 86% tem tem
perfil no facebook e todos de qualquer
classe social tem smartphone
então no timber também viu gente
a dona nilza que a vizinha de um amigo
meu e um colega de trabalho acabou de
arrumar um namorado
aos 88 anos e ela está feliz da vida
isso faz com esse novo comportamento
esse novo comportamento dos novos
maduros faz com que investidores estejam
olhando para a longevidade como
oportunidade para agarrar e silver
dólares toda aquela economia que eu
falei lá atrás e aí a gente começa a ver
grandes inovações nesse mercado
alguns deles são o election que é um
robô de companhia criada em israel para
ajudar pessoas mulheres principalmente
acima de 75 anos a viver mais tempo nas
suas casas
a iv e ao invés de ir para uma casa de
repouso ou provar ele pede que o nome
chique disso no brasil a gente tem aí o
game que é uma escola que ensina
programação ensina como programar para
pessoas com mais de 50 anos depois que
elas passam por este curso eles viram
professores de tecnologia e nos estados
unidos um sex shop que vende por e comer
se viu suas vendas bombarem depois que
eles criaram um vibrador específico para
o público 70 mais
além disso trouxe só alguns exemplos
vocês vêem que trabalhar com longevidade
é muito mais do que falar só sobre saúde
e previdência tem aí uma oportunidade
muito grande de inovar e trabalhar em
propósito em gestão financeira trabalhar
criar produtos para rotina para o
cuidado e também para o fim da vida
isso já está acontecendo hoje muito
provavelmente na casa de vocês por isso
há dois meses atrás decidi ir para o
japão para entender o que está
acontecendo lá no país que é o país mais
velho do mundo pra ver o que já está
acontecendo naquele laboratório a céu
aberto e aprender para trazer aqui para
o brasil
lá eu vi coisas como pessoas com mais de
80 anos trabalhando nas ruas enquanto
aqui a gente tem preconceito etária
dentro das empresas a partir dos 45 anos
de idade eu vi casas inteligentes mais
do que com robôs mas também com móveis
adaptados às vezes assim igual a gente
viu lá uma cama que vira uma cadeira de
rodas coisas práticas para o dia a dia e
também ex os esqueletos que como macacão
se coloca assim uma coisa meu deus você
coloca ea isso te faz tanto poupa a sua
coluna mas também de fato carregar mais
peso e isso também ajuda muito maduras a
se manterem no mercado de trabalho às
vezes trabalhando no aeroporto e até em
fábrica mas uma das coisas mais
impressionantes que eu vi foi que lá
idade é só um número o que importa mesmo
é se você está bem ou não
esta é uma realidade do japão mas muito
em breve
a gente vai estar vivendo isso aqui no
brasil esses 30% da população com mais
de 60 anos
e pra gente chegar nas mesmas condições
que hoje os maduros vivem no brasil a
gente tem que agir agora e eu acredito
que as empresas e os empreendedores têm
um papel muito importante nisso a gente
tem que criar produtos e serviços
melhores pra eles
a gente tem que incluí los nos nossos
planejamentos estratégicos ea gente tem
que começar a pensar também neles na
hora de fazer campanha na hora de fazer
publicidade porque eles não se sentem
reconhecidos
quero fazer então o convite e uma
provocação
que tal quando voltar quando vocês
voltarem para seus trabalhos
vocês pensem nos seus pais nos seus avós
ou se vocês são a desses maduros
revolucionários
quem sabe atuar nessa área porque de
fato você tem aí uma vantagem muito
grande já sabe muito bem a dor e as
oportunidades que estão faltando no
mercado
eu vou passar um vídeo de três avós que
são de outubro
então fazendo muito sucesso na internet
oi gente nós somos a voz da razão e
surgiu de helena sônia e nós temos um
canal no youtube
falamos sobre vários assuntos e agora
nos pediram para falar sobre essa troca
de experiência entre as gerações que eu
achava que era uma coisa impossível como
foi possível a nós e então hoje eu tenho
um filho um prazer enorme de conversar
com gente jovem de escutar eles
escutarem ea gente se diverte bastante
também
eu acho uma coisa na troca ótima porque
a gente ensina e aprende e convive com
gente moça
agora eu acho que o velho tem que tomar
uma postura assim como gay sai do
armário
o velho tem que sair da cristaleira pra
não ficar uma coisa antiga e mofada vai
para o sol velho
nós temos box elas são demais né gente o
futuro é velho mas o mercado de 60 mais
o mercado da longevidade já está
acontecendo agora então vamos juntos
obrigada
[Aplausos]